what's popping rockstars welcome back to
new rock stars it's me Mt and Mama Maya
someone just shot Gaia the secret
Invasion just kill off a major main
character in the final moments of
episode three well spoiler alert no Gaia
is probably just fine stay tuned and
I'll tell you exactly how Gaia Will
Survive getting shot in the chest and
even possibly becoming a major Marvel
Comics character brought to life in the
MCU and hey this video was sponsored by
Squarespace the all-in-one platform that
makes launching your own website a
breeze but of course I'm so happy that
secret invasion is here I'm Gonna Miss
This show when it's gone so be sure to
tune in to new rockstars every Wednesday
for our secret Invasion breakdowns and
even more secret Invasion discussion on
our newest channel the break room and
also like always you can grab some of
our awesome secret Invasion inspired
merch at nerdriot.shop to let people
know that you are not a scroll but those
shape-shifting allegations to rest today
at nerd riot.shop Heroes of Earth will
react
the only way we can counter that claim
this planet as our home
is to become super ourselves
are we no longer just change faces
we change powers
we're going to be uniquely programmed
weapons of mass destruction
all of us
super squads all right so Gaia was shot
and that wasn't awesome but what if I
told you she was just playing possible
that's right everybody Gaia is very
likely just fine and I'm not just saying
that thanks to all the promo material
that shows way more Gaia moments to come
but also thanks to a certain nerd
nerding out in the 90s named Maya Hansen
and her incredible work on the science
at the heart of Aldrich Killian's
extremist program a particular power
said that secret Invasion Episode 3
teases when graphic heals his hand after
getting a nice table stabbing from Talos
for not keeping gaia's name out of his
mouth at brunch for those
of you that don't remember extremist was
a scientific project made by the
organization Advanced idea mechanics or
aim not to be confused with AIM instant
messenger from when I was a teenager and
girls wouldn't reply to me I was only
talking to the Bots aim was a massive
think tank of scientists that Aldrich
Killian was a part of that formed to
work on technology that enhanced
Humanity's biological potential and
since Killian was a big old creeper he
used his creepy nerdy nerd skills to
come across Maya Hansen's incredible
work on cellular regeneration and
eventually ended up recruiting her to
aim in order for her to help Killian
make an army of super hot and
self-healing extremist soldiers like you
could literally chop their limbs off and
they'll just grow it back and then
breathe fire in your general direction
like a dragon would and that gave
our boy Anthony Edward Stark a massive
headache in Iron Man 3 that led to the
end of aldrich's Killian and all of his
plans all those extremist soldiers that
didn't immediately get arrested fled to
different parts of the world with one
such extremist Soldier choosing to take
part in Shia Ling's fighting tournament
in chongqi and because of this the
skrulls were able to locate at least one
of these extremist soldiers and the new
scroll Dr Dalton to experiment with the
genes in their blood to add extremist
tissue regeneration powers to the super
scroll biology With a Little Help from
the blue radiation room very likely the
same type of blue radiation that was the
main focus of Nick Fury's entire career
at the dark energy Mission facility in
Avengers 1. that's Project Pegasus y'all
as well as the same type of Tesseract
radiation that gave Captain Marvel her
powers and appears to be linked to the
Fantastic Four as well because remember
when I read Richards portaled in see
that energy kind of kind of weird right
I think that's Mighty interesting it's
almost like the Scrolls were inspired by
these people or something I don't know
and look guys having a website is a lot
like having a business card if you run a
business you kind of need one and that
means you need Squarespace Squarespace
is an all-in-one platform that provides
you with everything you need to do
whatever you need with your website
Squarespace has templates and designs
for every category and use case so even
if you're making your very first website
using Squarespace makes it super easy to
customize your look update content and
add features to fit your unique needs if
you're selling merch Squarespace makes
it easy to do that too you can design
your products then save time and money
by letting Squarespace handle production
inventory and shipping and if you're
selling any other kind of physical Goods
digital Goods or even a service
Squarespace makes it easy to build your
storefront and grow your business to
check it out yourself head to
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com new rockstars to save 10
off your first purchase of a website or
domain that is
www.squarespace.com new rockstars to
save 10 off your first purchase of a
website and domain we think Squarespace
once again for sponsoring this video you
guys are amazing but anyway speaking of
that blue radiation in Gaia we already
know from the promo material that Marvel
and Disney Plus have released that at
some point Gaia will end up using Dr
Dalton's blue dark energy machine to
give herself super scroll abilities much
like it appears graphic has already done
to their biology prior to their meeting
with Talos I believe that Gaia actually
super scrolled herself with extremist
superpowers prior to her leaving
Graphics compound but this moment was
not included in episode 3 to keep us in
suspense to make us think that Gaia
actually died when she was shot this is
what will likely save gaia's life after
being shot because if an extremist
Soldier can survive a freaking Iron Man
blast to the face that extremist
superpowers could easily pop a bullet
out of one's chest so long as the host's
heart isn't completely destroyed anyway
Gaia having the superpowers of the
extremist program will not only help her
fight against graphic for the second
half of this series but I believe it
will also bingaya as she starts her
journey in the MCU moving forward after
seeking Invasion because I do not
believe that Gaia was meant to be just
halos's daughter in the MCU oh no for I
believe the old rumors surrounding
Emilia Clarke's character and secret
Invasion are indeed true and that Gaia
giving herself super scroll powers in
episode 3 is ultimately setting up the
MCU arrival of the long-awaited Abigail
brand of Sword in the comics Abigail
brand is a half alien half-human mutant
hybrid who possesses a mutated biology
that allows her to both regenerate body
tissue quickly as well as generate heat
and fire from her hands she calls
herself Abigail brand because her hands
be random and she uses these powers to
ultimately become the director of all of
Sword itself protecting the Earth from
various extraterrestrial threats from
her sword space station but rapid
healing and shooting fire for one's body
that power set sounds extremely similar
to those of extremist soldiers don't you
think the extremist program is a form of
biological mutation after all a mutation
triggered by Maya Hansen science that
unlocks the brain's hidden biological
potential extremists harnesses our
bioelectrical potential and it goes
here this is essentially an empty slot
and what this tells us is that our mind
our entire DNA in fact is destined to be
upgraded Maya and Killian were so close
to unlocking the secret to making
mutants in the MCU but unfortunately
their Bad Karma caught up to them and
they both died before they got the
chance that's what you get for making
exploding terrorist people fortunately
for Gaia extremists will likely lead to
a complete rebirth for gaia's character
from Gaia to Abigail brand with the
first three episodes of her being just
Gaia and the last three episodes as a
mutated Gaia I feel like that's in
perfect symmetry right there and with a
cleverly written show about dualities
like secret Invasion I don't believe
that gaia's rebirth happening at the
start of the second half of the series
was a coincidence it very much seems
like Gaia is being set up to take
talos's place as Earth's Best alien
Defender by becoming the director of the
saber space station monitoring Earth
from orbit she is the perfect candidate
to be adapted into Abigail brand in the
MCU though I will say that Abigail bran
is not a sprawl in the Marvel comics
with a name like Gaia I can definitely
see the MCU setting Gaia up to be one of
Earth's Guardians just like the goddess
Gaia of myth but anyways thank you guys
so much for watching this video you can
follow me at Mass retainment on Twitter
if you guys want to see me tweet some
weird and some really fun secret
Invasion theories but also do not forget
to check out our many great merch
options over at nerdriot.shop and also
don't forget to subscribe to the break
room and the Deep dive we everywhere
baby but anyways thank you guys so much
for watching goodbye
[Music]